well if you've ever wanted to learn to
fly a plane but you thought it's just
too expensive now could be your chance
right there's a flight school in
Henderson all in aviation they're
celebrating International Aviation day
with discounts on flight lessons Captain
Candace is there have we been cleared
for takeoff Candace
just yet guys but you guys can come on
down here and give it a try I'm joined
of course by the president of also like
thank you so much for joining us tell us
a little bit about the special
promotions today yep so we're here with
the Cessna 172 and if you sign up today
you get to rent the airplane for 172
bucks an hour nice sounds awesome and
I'm joined by Carl May the flight
instructor here tell us about the
programs here and about that awesome
simulator yes that simulator is
incredible
um here you can do all of your flight
training from private to commercial
we'll integrate the flight simulator
into your training and get you through
as efficiently and effectively as
possible awesome Carl and of course I I
have a student here who's been here for
about two years Presley mobile said
thank you so much for joining us tell us
what your journey has been like uh my
journey has been very exciting very
interesting I never thought I would go
the miles and go the distance that I
have and I'm just very happy to be here
and continue this journey awesome she
got the bug guys and now she's
continuing to do it thank you so much
for joining us guys and for all the work
you're doing for the aviation Community
you guys the aviation Community needs
Pilots you can start your pilot career
today they're open they're ready and
waiting for you guys we have details on
the special promotions on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from all in
aviation it's Captain Candace Charles
I'm Candace Charles Allison eight news
now you never know we might find her in
another career soon